heavy shelling is continuing in Sudan's
capital Khartoum fighting is
intensifying between the Army and
paramilitary Rapid support forces people
there say looting is widespread a
neighboring chat has taken in the
largest number of refugees from Sudan
tens of thousands of people are fleeing
violence in the western Darfur region
same bus Ravi joins us now from the town
of adre that's on the border with Sudan
Zayn people arriving there in their
crowds what are they expecting from the
authorities
well we're here we are here as you say
inadre at the checkpoint between Chad
and Sudan and here we're seeing more and
more people every day arriving from the
city of Janina the capital of West
Darfur a place that people describe as
the Forgotten conflict not only though
in the war in Sudan but globally as a
forgotten conflict where there's been a
cycle of continued violence for
Generations I'm just going to step out
of the way to show you the terrain that
people have to cross to get into the
safety the relative safety of Chad if
you see just behind me that half-built
bridge uh people underneath it
beyond that the white trucks
communication Tower the people sort of
gathering together that is all Sudan we
just cross
into if we just cross that little
riverbed that muddy riverbed into Sudan
it would take just moments now what
we're seeing is security of forces here
the the Border post uh authorities are
telling us that on any given day a
hundred to five hundred people arrive
daily most of them from Al Janina there
are either chadians who were living and
working in Sudan returning home or
mostly Sudanese refugees trying to get
to Safe Haven trying to get to safer
places in Chad we spoke to one woman who
arrived and made her way to the area
underneath that bridge and what we're
seeing is as soon as people arrive the
chatty and authorities carry out customs
checks they are say that they are
looking for weapons they are desperate
to make sure that there is not even a
trickle of any kind of the violence
creeping into Chad they don't want to
see the conflict mushrooming here on
this side of the Border people go
through customs checks there usually
brought in on horse and carts then they
carry their belongings after they've
been checked load them into taxis and
move further into chat either to friends
and family or to refugee camps for those
that don't have any other place to go
one woman we spoke to said that she had
to leave part of her family behind and
come with a few relatives here we keep
hearing that narrative again and again a
family's torn apart she described
elginina as a place that she left today
as a place that is absolutely void of
any kind of security apparatus of any
kind of governance she said that there
is violence and shooting on a daily
basis it continues even now and that she
had to leave because she had no other
choice and those are the kinds of
stories the ongoing looting and the
ongoing killing that is happening in
elginia and we are hearing that it is
spreading to other parts of Darfur and
the governor the regional governor of
Darfur just a couple of days ago
declaring his State the state of Darfur
in Sudan as a disaster Zone calling for
more International intervention
International Aid groups to arrive and
help the humanitarian crisis as soon as
possible okay Zane thanks very much for
bringing us an idea of the situation
that in chat on the border with Sudan